[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace centroamérica desde
honduras en esta oportunidad hablaremos
sobre las amenazas a uno de los
principales pulmones vegetales de la
capital el parque nacional la tigra
debido a incendios forestales a la
construcción de urbanizaciones y a la
tala de sus árboles además conoceremos
uno de los viveros más grandes de
tegucigalpa que podría significar la
salvación de sus fuentes de agua y
finalmente comentaremos sobre el peligro
que corren los líderes ambientalistas en
este país centroamericano el caso más
sonado es el de la mundialmente
galardonada berta cáceres quien fue
asesinada tras oponerse a la
construcción de una represa
hidroeléctrica sobre las aguas del río
walk archer considerado sagrado por los
indígenas y vital para su supervivencia
[Música]
el parque nacional la tigra está ubicado
en las afueras de tegucigalpa es una de
las principales reservas naturales de la
capital tiene una extensión de 24 mil 40
hectáreas los recursos y las bondades de
este parque son de un valor incalculable
debido a la variedad de su flora fauna
recursos hídricos y forestales
la tigra está compuesta por tierra sin
bosque este es el lugar donde viven los
habitantes del parque y el núcleo donde
existen bosques de coníferas y bosque
latifoliado
una de las mayores importancia que tiene
el parque es que posee más de 70
quebradas que aportan agua para el
consumo humano para la protección y
administración de este pulmón fue creada
la organización amigos de la tigra una
ong creada en
1993 vía decreto congreso hondureño
ellos se encargan de recaudar fondos
para llevar a cabo acciones que permitan
la conservación de estos ecosistemas
tenemos los que es unas son los
patrullajes supervisión es inspecciones
denuncias que presentan la población
esto lo hacemos en conjunto con
diferentes organizaciones involucradas
en el manejo el parque
también dentro de todo eso atendemos los
que son incendios forestales
también hacemos trabajos de
investigación en el parque porque nos
permiten tomar algunas decisiones por
ejemplo los trabajos de investigación
tenemos lo que son cámaras trampas para
identificar qué tipos de mamíferos y
aves tenemos en el parque
sin embargo pese a estos esfuerzos de
protección la tigra vive bajo constantes
amenazas como los incendios forestales
la construcción de urbanizaciones y la
tala ilegal de bosques entre el 2011 y
2022 honduras ha perdido aproximadamente
650 mil hectáreas de bosque un promedio
de 70.000 hectáreas por año se estima
que por cada hectárea unos 2800 árboles
se queman en la zona de la tigra el
mayor impacto lo sufre el bosque
primario un bosque maduro que ha estado
allí por décadas hay épocas de incendio
para un ejemplo entonces involucrarse en
actividades de
construcción de rondas
y por ende si surgen incendios pues de
la misma manera involucrarse y
contrarrestar los incendios porque
sabemos qué
al dejar propagar esto lo que se pone en
peligro es
que se sequen los caudales de agua
verdad que son importantes para los
primeros que somos los habitantes que
somos los beneficiarios directos de este
recurso el daño ambiental causado a las
diferentes reservas forestales en
tegucigalpa ha provocado la reducción de
las diferentes fuentes de agua en ríos y
quebradas es por ello que la alcaldía
municipal del distrito central ha
fundado la unidad de gestión ambiental
uno de los propósitos es la creación de
diferentes viveros municipales
unos 150.000 árboles de este vivero son
sembrados en las partes más afectadas
por los incendios forestales
entre las variedades existentes en los
semilleros hay pinos roble cedro caoba
guanacaste ciprés acacias amarillas y
rojas entre otras la alcaldía municipal
está arborizado bulevares áreas verdes
ver a algunas micro cuencas algunas a
espacios públicos que necesitan de
árboles como lo hacemos pues a través de
colegios sociedad civil voluntarios
juntas de agua sociedad civil organizada
verdad para que nos pueda colaborar
junto con los empleados del alcaldía
municipal que donde falte uno o dos más
árboles nosotros estamos ahí para
colaborar ver la especie la cantidad de
árboles y de esta manera por lo que
estamos produciendo permanentemente en
los viveros municipales
proteger el medio ambiente en honduras
representa una seria amenaza para sus
activistas según la organización no
gubernamental global wind es honduras
siendo uno de los países más peligrosos
del mundo para quienes se dedican a
proteger el medio ambiente
mi mamá como ambientalista y como una
mujer entregada totalmente a esa lucha y
totalmente consciente y formada de
manera autodidacta en esos temas
dedicó su vida y esos años de lucha
fuerte como nunca antes porque ella
siempre había luchado en contra de los
madereros en contra de los
terratenientes en contra de la gente que
sacaba a los campesinos sin derechos de
la gente que destruye el bosque
el informe del global wind es revela que
honduras es el quinto país más peligroso
del mundo para los defensores del
ambiente y la tierra en el 2020 17 de
ellos fueron asesinados gracias por ver
nuestro programa enlace centroamérica
desde honduras si usted quiere volver a
vernos y sintonice nuestro sitio